i'm not opposed to the vaccine but i am
opposed to the mandate
people have died from covet i just don't
think we should we shouldn't have
misinformation on our air things got
real heated on the view tuesday between
jedediah bila and her former co-hosts
come on you've been at fox tv
the former fox and friends anchor
appeared on the daytime talk show to
promote her new book but it didn't take
long for co-host joy behar to address
the quote elephant in the room the 42
year old author was supposed to join the
show in studio weeks prior but couldn't
because abc requires everyone in the
building to be vast and well she isn't i
have a medical exemption to the vaccine
that's been written by my infectious
disease vaccinated specialist in new
york city that's been co-signed by three
other doctors i'm not a candidate for
this vaccine i also have sky-high
multi-tiered multi-faceted natural
immunity so for me personally this
vaccine poses a greater risk than a
benefit i'm also not a risk to any of
you i know there's been a lot of debate
about that but i have these doctors
who've gone on record with that as well
jedediah then noted that she's not
anti-vaxx but she thinks people should
talk to their doctors and make decisions
for themselves before saying that she
does oppose vaccine mandates the vaccine
does not prevent you from getting
coveted and does not prevent you from
transmitting oh my goodness
yeah so the ladies of the view weren't
feeling that at all and let it be known
that is why masks were reinstated for
people who were vaccinated because they
said and they admitted they came out and
said this for this delta variant
transmission is going to be a thing for
vaccinated
people
i'm not opposed to the vaccine but i am
including manny's in-laws and i just
we've been friends a long time but i
just manny's parents i just don't
understand why you would choose to
prioritize your personal freedom over
health and safety of others but before
the argument was over sunny hostin got
one final message across
we've had the united states surgeon
general debunk yes i heard what he said
everything that you've just said and i
just don't think we should we should
kind of misinformation on our air
of course the name sunny mentioned
before manny is her husband
and back in january she revealed during
an episode of the view that both of his
parents died from covet 19. they were
both physicians
and they were both very careful we want
to thank the doctors and nurses that
gave them such incredible care
they're doing god's work
letting us face time uh with with uh
manny's parents
uh while they were uh passing away
jedediah made her best effort to
reassert her argument but sonny wouldn't
let up i'm really sorry first of all i'm
really sorry first of all i would say to
you as a friend what i just said to you
is i am prioritizing my health and
people talk about the comments over the
health and safety you're not going to
have a covenant but if you're not
prioritizing your own health you have
responsibilities this should sound bad
this should sound very familiar to you
jed
this should sound very familiar to you
we got to go to break gotta love a good
commercial break to break the tension of
course the view is no stranger to a
heated debate in fact back in 2019
former co-host megan mccain told et she
thinks that's part of the show's appeal
i mean i think that's why people like
the show is they know it's not scripted
and they know it's not we're not being
phony and i'm not trying to placate to
an audience megan exited the show
earlier this year leaving four ladies on
the panel and when e.t caught up with
sunny joy and their fellow co-hosts
whippy goldberg and sarah haynes back in
september they opened up about returning
to the studio for the first time in two
years with less ladies at the table
it's much more fun to have
fewer people i think because you can
talk more and you know more people can
see we can say more to each other even
it became like i gotta get a word in
here now you know it was i don't i don't
love that but we've learned how to do
that now the opposite of that was being
alone in your house which is what we
were for the past two years and now as
would be like well what do you think and
then all of a sudden i have to give a
speech i didn't love that i didn't love
that i like the audience i like the
camaraderie i like the fun of it which
is what this is about now and this is
why the view is popular for this exact
reason
[Music]
you